are you guys after all these years
together are you nervous about
performing a 10-minute song on my show
the world is listening as you know
everyone in the world listens to this
show you've never performed it live how
many times have you actually rehearsed
this twice
really
we've played it a few more times in that
i think it's definitely nerve-wracking
because there's some tricky kind of
timing intersections and and weird
little segues it's a challenge it's
quite nice to feel to feel challenged
and to feel the pressure of her of a
live performance and we as an audience
are not only going to try to enjoy it
but we're also going to sit here and see
if we can find mistakes don't be too
nervous boys i'm here with you i know
you're rehearsed this is quite exciting
howard
stay with me rob and excitement will
always be in your life
thank you thank you robin we love you
guys very much
[Music]
[Music]
everyone before us is there welcoming us
now
it's the end of death and doubt
when loneliness
[Music]
the place we dreamed about
the melodies inside yourself a love come
pouring out
[Music]
everyone's allowed
we're feathered by the crowd
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so it's
[Music]
we're a slow
[Music]
in this
crazy world
i do
[Music]
i just want you
[Music]
in the end it's all about
the love
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the explorer
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
in this
crazy world
i do
i just
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all the satellites
the purple yellow green red
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm in this crazy
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
i just want
you
[Music]
[Music]
oh it's prophesied
together
[Music]
ah
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
the end
beautiful
that didn't seem like 10 minutes to me
in fact boys the bad news is it was only
9 minutes and 58 seconds you have to do
it again until you get it right uh i
detect the problem wow
you